Film Courage: From having grown up in the business
watched your father and your grandfather
how did you know you had the skills that
would make you a successful editor? You
knew what you probably didn't want to do
but how did you know you had the
temperament, the patience, an ability to be
alone in the editing room? Lawrence Jordan, ACE and Owner of Master The Workflow: I didn't know. I
just knew I loved movies and I loved
editing but when I was working in my
father's trailer house I started to get
a pretty good understanding of what was
required of of an editor he even let me
work on some you know promo reels and
sizzle reels and a couple of trailers
even when I was just sort of like
schlepping stuff so you know I was
really able to get my hands dirty but I
had him over my shoulder to you know
kind of tell me where to cut essentially
when I when I when when I was lost and
again you know because I had been
playing with those splicers and the 35
millimeter film and the tape and the
rewinds since I was a little boy there
was there was sort of just like an inner
knowledge I just I just was confident in
in the mechanics you know what really
sort of became you know the challenge
and the learning experience was was
learning you know about you know story
and and how to tell stories and although
I didn't have a formal film school
education I took a lot of night classes
particularly at UCLA Extension and I
studied you know I studied story
screenwriting classes but more
importantly I studied a lot of theater
classes and you know learned about the
the great plays and sort of did some you
know took some critical analysis classes
and things
like that at night and you know that's
the thing that you kind of have to learn
as you go if you don't have a formal
film school education and also I think
it's really important that you trust
your gut you know as an editor and I
think that a lot of editors will tell
you that a lot of it is instinctual you
know from everything from when a
performance doesn't seem to be you know
playing - when a scene doesn't seem to
be playing - when an act doesn't seem to
be playing - when the whole movie
doesn't seem to be playing I mean you
really break it down you know -
individually you can break it down to a
small an element as an individual shot
so you know that that really came over
time and and luckily I did have
excellent mentors who you know pulled no
punches and we're very blunt about what
works and what doesn't work for them and
you know it's that was part of the
business on film that we kind of don't
have as much anymore I think maybe some
editors work that way but because of a
digital were much more siloed and we
work in in in separate sort of rooms and
assistants are very busy with their
chores a lot of it has as before
assistants has become metadata
management working on the computer
input/output you know tracking things
like that whereas you know when you were
a first assistant on film sometimes you
would just stand next to the editor as
he or she were editing and you'd be
handing them film because otherwise
they'd have to turn around and that
would break their thread and things like
that and you you know it was a much more
sort of interactive process between an
assistant and an editor and you you know
literally sit over their shoulder and
watch them you know create cuts so you
know that's kind of the way I was taught
about performance and and and
storytelling and you know taste in terms
of you know what what might be best who
were most appropriate in a scene
did I answer your question you did
so having grown up in the industry and
also there was this like instinctual
thing because you had been around the
mechanics of it was there anything where
it surprised you where you were not sure
that it was the right career for you
whatever it was whether I will tell you
that yeah I will tell you there there
was a point when early on when you know
video tape was becoming very prevalent
and people were video editors were these
people who seemed like a combination of
mathematicians and science nerds and I
am NOT either I have a great respect for
science but I I'm not a scientist and
and there was a lot of numbers always
happy to punch in time code numbers and
things like that with the videotape and
then rolling back and forth and not
being able to like just put a cut in
there into the videotape you know like
you could with film you know because I
came from film and you know I I was
worried because I thought videotape is
the future you know in Francis Ford
Coppola was cutting films on videotape
and and I was thinking oh man I'm gonna
piccoli here because I really don't like
this stuff I really liked the 35
millimeter or 16-millimeter movie olace
and and you know what I had grown up
with and but as you know things would
would come to pass I was working on a
film called little man Tate with Lindsay
Clingman who you know was another mentor
and an amazing editor and I got a phone
call from my father who had kind of
semi-retired but I think he was still
sort of doing something screwing around
maybe a little bit here and there and he
said they're cutting they're cutting
films on hard drives now and I'm like
why what are you talking about he's all
you you know you've got to see this and
I had kind of heard about this and was
ignoring it because I was too busy
working on a film but then they ran into
some people and they talked about a
couple of different systems that were
out there but then I can't remember who
I think was my dad said there's this
thing called the avid and it's a
computer-based editing system and I said
get out of town and concurrently while
working on little man Tate Jodie Foster
had this beautiful color screen
Macintosh in her office and I just
thought that was the coolest thing ever
I had a computer at home but it was an
old IBM clone and Jodie was very cool
about it she was like yeah you can play
with that one you know whenever you want
you know you can kind of screw around on
that and so I was kind of like screwing
around in the Macintosh and I was just
so you know hypnotized by the graphical
user interface it was it was like a
video game to me and although I don't
play video games but anyhow so we go to
see a demo my dad and I go to see a demo
of the avid media composer and in an
instant I saw that that was my future
this was the future of editing and
because it was nonlinear it was the same
as film except it was on the computer
you didn't have to
it wasn't like video tape which was you
know which was linear and you had to you
know rerecord the entire sequence if you
wanted to make a change in one place so
yeah it was I would say to say it was
like a bolt of lightning would be an
understatement
I literally you know would look at those
movie owners after that and say these
things are dinosaurs and they are
destined for the for the dustbin of
history or they anyway and so after that
I took a year off to kind of work with
my dad again and immerse myself into
digital technology in the app and Media
Composer I'm sorry what year was this
little man Tate was what 1990 would 90
okay yeah Wow
so it was this at like a hotel like
where did they have this
no I haven't had offices in Burbank oh I
see and they had started to make inroads
in commercials because the images the
digital images at that time were very
pixelated they almost look like a Dali
painting and you know that was the thing
well you know this is great but we're
not gonna cut features like this you
know so and of course the sales people
there and the representatives there were
like well yes but the next generation of
picture quality is going to be much
better and you know fine fine fine
and it wasn't ready for primetime in
features but people were using it for
commercials and I said I need to learn
everything I can about this because this
is coming this is the future this is how
I'm going to be an editor if I'm going
to be an editor indeed and and the
picture quality did improve and I spent
a lot of time immersing myself into the
Macintosh operating system and the
hardware that made the Macintosh
operating system work which was pretty
foreign to me I mean I wasn't a computer
you know engineer or anything like that
I I you know frightened of it just like
anybody else and oh my god am I gonna
erase everything and things like that
but I spent really literally almost a
year getting my hands dirty and you know
after that year I I had no fear and I
could pull apart a computer and I was
ready to I was ready to go having that
experience how does that going forward
when you see a new technology or or a
hint of it you read about it in the Wall
Street Journal whatever how does that
make you feel because so many people
could shun it and say oh that'll never
happen
like they said Amazon oh that that will
fail you know the nothing that will
never take off and it's it's changed the
world it's changed how we consume things
but so many people in the beginning did
you know how does that make you look at
things now well it's different now
because
you know that was the beginning of the
of the computer era for personal
computer era and it was also the
beginning of the era of computer editing
and the adoption of editing in that in
that manner everything is done on the
computer now so I I look at it with you
know with interest I mean I remember
when somebody told me about uber and he
said uber this is the next big thing and
I'm like uh-huh and I mean it was years
before I even understood what it really
like so I mean you know in terms of our
industry I think there's still a lot of
exciting things because what's happening
is you know the products continue to get
more powerful and cheaper and you know
things to make films continue to get
more powerful and and relatively cheaper
and I get excited by that kind of stuff
I always been excited by the idea of
being able to put technology in more
people's hands and have an and have
people you know all kinds of people have
a voice in the media creation industries
so but you know AI and and you know
virtual reality and 3d I mean you know
I've seen 3d come like three or four
times in my lifetime so come and go so
IMAX you know I think IMAX is is great
for you you know what it is but I do I
think that's gonna change or take over
the entire industry or have any kind of
real lasting impact I'm not sure you
know there's all kinds of stuff out
there I I imagine that some of them are
going to kind of really take hold some
of these
immersive technologies but I don't know
you're making me feel very old-fashioned
if it made you bit sorry I wasn't my it
wasn't my digit so what does it make you
feel like less of a skeptic or more so
because you like that's truly I think
was it even in the 50s they had the 3d
glasses or them with jaws and these
different things and and and we weren't
really sitting around wearing them and
then we were told we were going to but
but different things where where this is
going to be the new the new wave does it
make you more of a skeptic or less so as
you saw well you know one of the things
that I didn't want to get into the
commercial advertising business one of
the reasons I didn't want was because
there's so much hype you know and and
I'm skeptical of hype you know I like to
you know if I see a technology that I
that I think has been a really you know
sort of bear fruit or empower people or
be fantastic
you know I'll check it out and I'll
really like kind of get into it but you
know the next big thing I'll give you an
example there's there's a project up at
Stanford which is and I think Adobe's
involved in it where they're
experimenting with artificial
intelligence as it applies to editing
and you know there was some hubbub about
it last year and do I think artificial
intelligence is going to replace editors
probably not in the not in in the near
future will it will it maybe augment
editing at some point in time probably
you know I think that there's kind of
like a lot of hype about artificial
intelligence in general I don't you know
I think that's kind of overblown to tell
you the truth it's just my opinion I I
don't think that there's going to be
anything that's gonna obsolete us humans
anytime soon I think probably get a lot
of help from computers continue to get a
lot of help but I also think that
there's
know that humans operate on a different
kind of level in terms of consciousness
and things like that the computers just
don't have and no one has shown me
otherwise so I don't know you know
nothing that exciting has has come along
but what is exciting is the improvement
of the tools for what I deal with you
know for digital editing for filmmaking
so I'm excited about that stuff
you